because of all the things that are
constantly going on in the world and
also because gay marriage is now legal
nationally in the united states
sometimes it's easy to get the sense
that the old school violent homophobia
of like kill the gays is over in the
united states it is not over and i'm
going to play some video for you today
of a christian pastor in arlington texas
who wants gay people killed and is very
much against the pride parade there was
a city council meeting in arlington
texas the point of it was
let's hear comments about whatever is on
people's minds and uh this christian
pastor is very much against the pride
parade these exist all over the country
they're generally supportive of lgbt
rights uh pretty uncontroversial at this
point in time and this homophobic mega
preacher in arlington texas show up
shows up and says gays are an
abomination
they should be executed i mean listen
that's what god says so listen to this
that this is still very much a thing and
the the scariest part is you'll hear
people in the crowd going yep
right
they agree with it according to god we
should hate pride
not celebrated we should humble
ourselves as
virtually the whole room said that we
were a nation under god according to the
american flag and we were a state under
god if we're in the texas flag we should
humble ourselves to what the bible says
and not what the small minority here
that is bullied would say amen
in june of 2020 mayor jeff williams
officially announced the acceptance of
pride month in june
for the city of arlington
but i don't understand why we'd
celebrate what used to be a crime not
long ago
yep you hear those people yep according
to the texas penal code
and section 219
homosexual conduct a person commits an
offense if he engages in deviated sexual
intercourse with another individual of
the same sex in fact that is still on
the books today even though
lawrence versus texas overruled that in
2003
but god has already ruled that murder
adultery witchcraft rape bestiality and
homosexualities are crimes worthy of
capital punishment leviticus 2013 the
bible says a man also lie with mankind
as a lion with a woman both of them have
committed an abomination they shall
surely be put to death their blood shall
be they should be put to death and
people in the crowd say amen upon them
romans 1 says that men with men are
worthy of death second peter chapter two
warns and says that in turning the
cities of sodom and gomorray to ashes
condemn them with an overthrow making
them an example of those that after
should live ungodly and deliver
it is 2022
and they're still talking about
death
for gay people you know back in 2008 i
would do interviews like this
where people would say this stuff but we
like to believe it's not going on
anymore and he kept going with the
homophobic stuff and the crowd kept
saying yep yep according to cdc
homosexual men are 230 times more likely
to get hiv than straight men i don't
know why we promote
disease and aids in our community
additionally according to this article
of self-reported crimes the lgbt have an
average of 20 to 150 children victims
and including they commit an average of
154 acts on their victims now here's the
thing they say that they love so much
but they hate children they hate
baptisms they hate christianity
so this is the the gays or pedophiles
thing which is like this is old school
homophobia now i know many of you will
say david you know
leviticus which they often cite
leviticus also says eating shrimp is an
abomination but they all eat shrimp
what's up with that and it's true if you
look at leviticus it does say that when
you eat from the waters whatsoever hath
fins and scales in the waters
them shall ye eat
and all that have not fins and scales
they shall be an abomination unto you
that's what leviticus says and you would
say well but how can they point to
leviticus for the anti-gay stuff but
then they ignore all these other parts
of leviticus they simply talk about the
new covenant they've they've figured it
out guys they have a response to this
they say no no no no no
uh we christians
we
have been promised the new covenant
which was instituted at the last supper
as part of the eucharist
and it replaces the dietary law
but it didn't replace the anti-gay parts
so they they've got an answer for that i
know you and i would look at it and we
would say how hypocritical they'll be
picking and choosing but no and in fact
they won't just cite leviticus for the
anti-gay stuff they'll talk about what's
in timothy and what's in corinthians and
on and on and on from the new testament
so i know that it doesn't make any sense
it's hypocrisy it's picking and choosing
it's all this stuff that we're very used
to
but at the same time at the same time
uh they are continuing even though it's
2022. horrifying stuff